bachelor nation I told you as a
bachelorette kind of morning and we have
an absolute legend of the franchise here
and Bushnell thank you for being here I
mean I had to give you that intro not
only because I love you and you're the
sweetest but because look what she
brought me everybody
dear Jose is your rose a brand this is
roses and rose a live so oh my gosh we
are about to pop this rose a on a
Tuesday morning can you do the honors
can you open this up I mean it's such a
hard tell me about why you wanted to
make a rose a and like tell me about so
yeah I mean I've always loved Rose a
especially I mean I feel like the last
couple years roses become just such a
popular drink because it is so easy to
enjoy no matter what time of day whether
it's ten o'clock on a Tuesday you know
and it's just one of those things
especially in California it's just a
drink then I personally it was my go-to
Cheers no yeah Cheers
what a boss lady it's amazing you guys
should brought it in an igloo ding for
me to keep it cold it's so good I've
never had it before but you were killing
it you're selling it you're in different
restaurants this is a venture between
you and your boyfriend Damon so how what
does that like to work together and be
in a relationship yeah
okay so when we first started it I
remember specifically like so many
people thing like are you sure you want
to do that because you hear about it all
the time like things that just can go
kind of a rye whether it's like married
couples working together or whatever but
for us it's actually really fun that's
been challenging at times and we have to
work through things but I think it's
forced us to communicate better it's
forced us to kind of be creative
together and like have this shared kind
of project and shared passion now
together which i think is really cool
it's awesome you guys I'm sure that you
have so many questions and comments for
Lauren as I do so leave the money to
social platforms right now I will get
them here on our iPad and we are also
going to of course recap last night's
episode of The Bachelorette which Becca
kufran what we were saying this is so
funny that you're here because you went
to
Bahamas on your season last night they
went to the Bahamas but you felt like
you had a different experience I felt
like their Bahamas was maybe a little
more glamorous stars and maybe that's
just again the TV effect but their
weather looked a little nice okay ours
our weather was a little gloomy the
Bahamas for me and I think for our
season as a whole was just a little
weird it was a weird time because of the
weather because weather there was like
that weird two-on-one it was gloomy
everyone this I was telling you this the
second ago everyone got kind of sick I
don't know if it was or what but it was
just an interesting time it's
interesting that you say that because a
lot of people have said that they feel
like the dates and everything that's
happening on this season have not been
as glam as seasons past like they're not
maybe doing the trips or the big moments
or like no over-the-top dates do you
feel like as somebody who was on the
show as a contestant like is it better
to build the relationship to have a more
normalized date or to have one of those
glamorous dates like what's better in
this environment to connect with the
person mean I would definitely say the
more normal date okay because I just
think obviously like the glam the glitz
and all that stuff it can kind of build
that excitement that maybe gets confused
with actual feelings and the romance and
stuff and I think that's great and it's
fun and it it works but I do I would
personally prefer the more normal dates
and the less glam because I just feel
like it gives you a chance to really
kind of see what real life would
actually be like you're obviously not
gonna be flying in a helicopter
you're not going here it's not gonna
happen so let's talk a little bit about
last night's episode it was a lot of
like one-on-one on the beach then dinner
one-on-one on the beach then dinner um
we had Blake Blake got his beach time
and then he got his dinner let me get
your thoughts on Blake because Blake was
sort of having this moment of you know
he's having a hard time accepting that
she has feelings for the other guys
which it's like don't you know what this
show is yeah but then I was surprised
Beca said that she was in love with
Blake but of course she couldn't tell
him yet what do you think that action
well I was just a little thrown off by I
mean I understand having a hard time
because I get it especially at that
point there are feelings developing and
of course it's hard to see someone that
you are really falling for go on a date
with someone else like that's not fun
but he really was struggling and I was
just
surprised by that and but yeah I mean I
was surprised but I'm also not and she
even said it I think where she said I
understand how Ari felt and you know how
past bachelor and bachelorettes feel
because it happens time and time again
where they you fall you can fall for two
different people and and real in real
feelings too so yeah I mean I'm not
surprised but I think it probably puts
her in a hard position I mean as a
contestant how difficult is it to be in
that moment and you know after the show
to look back and be seeing no she did
because I was thinking like wills was
just hearing him like was that weird for
you to watch and see that she at that
point felt like she was in love with
Blake yeah um
oh gosh watching it back like you know I
obviously like I I have no idea who
she's in a relationship with or if she
is or how the show ends but I'm sure
that's not fun to watch back in general
like and which is why I don't think I
watched most of my season back
especially towards the end because it's
like you don't need to relive that we
all know what happens we all know that
you there are real feelings for other
people you don't need to rewatch it and
bring it back into the relationship so
better than not watch it I wouldn't
watch it Blake also when they were at
dinner made this kind of crazy
confession about his family I was really
surprised he said you know that he'd
gotten his parents gotten divorced when
he was in high school and he told her
that his mom had an affair with his a
coach I was like oh did mom know you
were gonna I know that was literally my
first thought I was like oh gosh like
and his mom gonna be on the hometown
like it's gonna be awkward that was my
first thought but I mean I feel like
he's clearly an emotional person
mhm which I respect and he kind of wears
his heart on his sleeve which i think
has been very evident and so if he felt
like he needed to kind of tell her and
if he does feel like that's where a lot
of his feelings are stemming from I
think it's good he told her but yeah
thanks probably I don't know how long he
was a lot of oversharing last night you
know we'll get into a mogera talked
about his ex it was yeah I mean yeah do
you are you so in the bubble at that
time or did you try to have an awareness
of like I need to be careful about what
I tell about my past and my family I
think for me I was a little bit reserved
and probably over thought too much which
made it hard for me to fully like let my
guard down and which is why I don't
think I got super
super-emotional a lot and it was because
yeah you're very for me at least i was
so hyper aware that there's twenty
people around you it's not if it wasn't
if it was just myself and Ben at the
time or I think I would have had no
problem letting my guard down
but I mean again that's why I'm like
good for him for ya kind of being able
to just block everything else out and be
like that present where he's comfortable
enough to just kind of well I was guards
I'm sure at all well it's kind of funny
cuz I think people thought he's a
front-runner he got the first one-on-one
and then it felt a little surprising to
hear her say she was in love with him
because we hadn't seen much of him on
recent episodes and I wondered if you
related to that or wanted to speak to
that at all because you know obviously
you and Ben ended up together but like
you just said you were more reserved did
you feel like oh they didn't show a lot
of moments to be had because maybe they
were trying to throw people off or did
you feel like oh I was you know maybe I
wasn't coming out with it as much
because the feelings were real like what
was your experience like with that I
think in general it was probably a
little bit of both I think looking back
on the show I was definitely like very
reserved and quiet which I think by
nature I am but especially when put in
that situation I was like a deer in
headlights yeah so I think for me at
least it was probably a little bit of
both and probably same for them because
I remember watching the first few
episodes and I was like oh like likes
definitely like a front-runner yeah and
so it's probably both yeah yeah it is
funny to how the I was here when Nick
vile was here he said he he actually did
not give Vanessa his first impression
rose because he was worried she'd get
like a target on her do you feel like
people who are the frontrunners like get
that target on them or get that
criticism and how do you deal with it if
so yeah I think maybe more so with the
women from what I've at least seen I
feel like on our season definitely a
little bit but not as much we had like a
good group of mm-hmm I don't think we
had a dramatic group of girls but yeah I
could see that definitely it's I mean
there's that competitive nature where
especially when you like someone it you
don't want to see someone else kind of
right you don't wanna view someone
else's the
front runner yes not a good feeling to
have so yeah I could see how coming the
first like for an in next case would
kind of shy away from that which is
sweet because he was protecting her yeah
let's take a drink Blake thank you power
through you know it's a struggle for you
got this Blake so good so many comments
coming in for you Gina wants to know are
you dating well yeah she's dating Sarah
wants to know who your favorite guy is
so real quick let's get who your
favorite um I like Blake and I really
like Garrett so Jared we well first
let's talk a little bit about Colton
Coleman you know he had the sexy moment
with her on a boat he also confessed
we had big night of confessions that he
is a virgin you know people were acting
like it was gonna be this you know how
would she react
how would she react if a guy you were
dating told you how would i yes I was so
taken aback by this because I don't know
if it was just the filming or the
editing or whatever but it looked like
she was having to really really sit this
one through and thinking through and and
really like yet one with this new
revelation yeah and for me like I don't
know it wouldn't bother me if anything
if anything I would think it's really
cool and honestly probably will save
them from a lot of problems now well I
mean you know what I mean like love it
if my boyfriend didn't have a past
well Becca actually tweeted an update
and she said that when she walked away
she went to the bathroom so there you
guys seem to be an editing thing are
there any moments when you're looking
back and you're like that was an edited
totally right when I was on I think I
can't think of anything specifically but
I think like I remember like I'm very
expressive at times and there were a
couple of facial facial expressions I
remember making on the show and they
would show me making that expression
after someone said something but I don't
remember it being like directly after
what I'm saying
so maybe like little things like that
but that's funny though I didn't see
that she said she was yeah that's my
fear I'm like they would meet they what
maybe it's like you know I don't know I
was like making a face cuz I was really
bloated and yeah they would use that
face for something else yes
exactly so Colton Colton made his big
confession of course we said goodbye to
Leo Leo you know I just felt like with
Leo the connection wasn't really that
far along it felt like she kind of knew
she was gonna say goodbye yeah I was
kind of confused yeah yeah yeah you guys
can you get a sense with the contestants
can you get a sense of like it seems
like sometimes people are very surprised
by who goes home and sometimes they're
not like maybe who on your season were
you shocked when that person got sent
home you thought oh no they really have
a connection here um oh goodness
probably I remember when Jen Saviano
went home oh yeah but but then looking
back like she even told me she was like
I had a hard time like completely
opening up but like at the time cuz I
had gotten to know her and I was like
she's such like a catch like she's
stunning I remember being pretty
surprised and like honestly sad when she
went home but again like when you're in
it I feel like it's more obvious as a
viewer but when you're in the show you
don't really see like those interactions
so everything's kind of surprising
because I'm like I have no idea yeah you
know I just assume that he has a
connection with everyone like I have no
idea but I feel like it's a viewer it is
a little bit more obvious yeah like for
instance in this case I was like okay I
don't really see it between them we're
not seeing it so we know you and Amanda
Stan are still such good friends who
else from your season are you still
close with um I'm close with the twins
I'm close with Jen Saviano and lb who
she she left actually early on in the
season and then I talk with Becca
occasionally I talk with Jojo
occasionally she just launched her
clothing line I know and I was out of
town but I really wanted to go to her
lunch I feel like there's no one that
I'm like not friend friendly with but
I'm definitely closest with like the
twins and Amanda and Jen and lb you guys
had such a good season of girls and I
was kind of talking to you about this
before cuz I think about it a lot like
your season felt like so many of you
guys have kind of stayed in the realm
and you know we also follow you on
Instagram and it felt very genuine but I
now look sometimes I do wonder like
Instagram has just blown up even in such
a short amount of time and I do wonder
are people going on the show
more now because they know like oh I'll
have this Instagram fame from the show
do you get that feeling being in the
world I mean I think it's hard to not
think that that's maybe a part of it
yeah I mean obviously like it's become I
remember when I went on the show I had
no idea that it was kind of like on the
cusp of social media kind of exploding
and influencers being a thing I didn't I
didn't even know if I knew the word the
term influencer or if it was a term
quite yet and and I kind of understood
that maybe depending on how far you went
you might have like a moment like a 15
minutes of fame and like maybe a little
following but I had no idea kind of this
platform that you can possibly have and
I think myself I'm not the only one who
felt like I think it was kind of
unanimous amongst our season which did
kind of breed this like genuine vibe and
people who actually just wanted to meet
Ben and Ben was such a good guy so
obviously like that helped as well but
yeah I mean I can't help but feel the
same way it's like you just how do you
know like that's why I don't even know
if I would want to be in the position of
the bachelor or the Bachelorette it's
like how do you know if people are there
you know I hate the word for the right
reasons
yeah I think it's so overused but it's
kind of true how do you know yes you
really have to kind of be able to like
read through that I guess yeah I don't
know at this point it is more difficult
now yeah
so my gosh so many questions coming in
Christina wants to know who is your
personal pick for Becca who are you
really liking I really like I really
like Blake I do like him and I like
Garrett but I just think Garrett like
seems like a little more even mmm-hmm
tempered or like just kind of chill
vibes and I feel like Becka seems really
like laid-back too but I think either
but I'm gonna go Garrett okay I like
Garrett yeah I liked Blake's dancing
last night speaking of not chill vibes
they really liked that he hit the sand
for the Bob he really went for it 2:40
which I respect I respect about how men
were still around I know and he's so
cute he really is you grace wants to
know where can we get your Rose a so
online right now on our website dear
Weinstock
komm we're also launching a really
exciting campaign with saucy which is an
on-demand delivery yes so yes if you're
ever at home and already have had a
glass of wine and can't drive you can
order our wine on there in the next week
or two and then hopefully we really
obviously want to get into some
retailers so people can just grab us off
the shelf that's the goal the goal yes
thank you you guys it is kind of well so
we have to wrap up pretty soon here but
I wanted to also call out it was just
real funny guys I know everybody was a
little bit upset that we had to break
because president Trump announced the
next Supreme Court nominee so hopefully
everybody had a glass of wine during
that and we can all just move forward
you know we had that Trump moment and
that was kind of wild bachelor nation
had some reaction but you know things
are important more important than who's
getting the rose sometimes I do want to
catch up with you before we go just like
you said you're working on this with
Devin which is so wonderful I mean we
have people asking you know like are you
dating yes they are how long have you
guys been together and how are things
going it's been a year which is crazy
it's we're doing really well it's
definitely been I feel bad because I
feel like we did start like in hindsight
I think we started dating like I wish I
would have taken a little bit more time
but it just that's the way it went like
it naturally evolved we had known each
other before I went on The Bachelor and
we're friends and so but I do feel bad
because like I went through very hard
public breakup and I do think I brought
a lot of those like emotion into me and
Devin's relationship at the beginning
and so it's definitely been like a
rollercoaster of a ride and you know
like he doesn't understand all of this
stuff and he's very confused by it
especially at first when all people
wanted to ask me about was then and it
was hot he was such a trooper and so
we've been through a lot together but I
think that makes us like that much
stronger
so we're doing really well I love that
how did you kind of get through that
when you say he was such a trooper I
mean did you have to talk him through
and say like stick with me through this
I've got to deal with all this how do
you get through that
honestly like I never had to talk him
the cliff like he was just always very
supportive but there were times where he
was like hey this is really hard for me
like and I never really stopped and
thought about gosh that must be like I
never really put myself in his shoes at
first cuz it was just kind of like I was
just kind of also in the moment dealing
with it all but now looking back I'm
like gosh he really had to kind of hear
a lot of things that you don't really
want to hear about the person you're
you're now like in love with and dating
you know so I mean I think it was just
like communication and just trying to be
understanding of where each other is
coming from but he was always so
supportive of me
he really was what is it that makes you
not just that support but what other
qualities make you really happy with
this guy he is very like I can be a
little I can stress out about little
things and try to like look too much
into the future and plan too much and
he's very much like no like let's just
enjoy this moment take it day by day
he also pushes me like with the rose' I
feel like I have all these ideas but I
never know where to start so I never
actually start and he's the person who's
like no like let's start here multicore
gonna make this happen so he really does
like push me to kind of do things that
I've dreamt of or things that I'm
passionate about or want to do and not
push me in a way that's like aggressive
just really like lightly kind of kind of
like give me that little nudge that
maybe I need at times yeah which is
really cool and I've never really like
had someone who does that for me yeah
yeah what was that like for you because
you know like you said you went through
a tough breakup and I know I mean I just
remember sitting like the criticism you
got on social media at that time what
was the key for you to getting past that
was Devin the key for it or what was it
yeah he was like super yes he helped me
a lot I think it was my friends and my
family and then honestly I think it was
just not reading it I just had to take a
step back and for for a while there I
just didn't read anything and I still
really don't like there's there was a
lot of stuff out there that I could have
been deep into like reading and I just
for me personally it was better to just
not even look and kind of continue about
my life but yeah he was definitely a key
part in helping me kind of stay grounded
and like not listen to
and but I mean I still when you hear
something it's obviously still it sticks
with you so what was the hardest part
about that time was it the criticism
from people what was good toughness I
think it was the criticism I think it
was like I was sad about the breakup and
I was going through a lot of changes I
was like moving my life and like trying
to like resettle and get my like footing
underneath me and um and I was and I was
sad and I felt I had like I felt like I
had failed I felt like all these
emotions that you feel on a breakup
right but then it was also on a very
public scale and I did feel like you
know I think everyone always wants there
to be someone at fault or a reason why
or like someone wants to point the
finger and I think because I started
dating Devin so soon after I was kind of
an easy like target for the reason for
the breakup or whatever and so that was
obviously hard but you know breakups are
hard whether you met on the bachelor or
not like breakups Huck and you know when
you look back I mean I feel like your
life it's kind of crazy we were talking
about bachelor time feels longer because
so many shows happen but really in a
pretty short amount of time you move to
Colorado you move back you don't work as
a flight attendant anymore now you have
this other job like what have you kind
of learned about yourself as you English
I think I learned that I'm a lot
stronger than I thought I was because
you know growing up I'm so thankful I
had such a steady upbringing my family's
together I literally my parents to live
in the house that I grew up in so I
didn't experience a ton of change and
then all the sudden in such a short
amount of time like you said I moved I'm
a bad guy was engaged I wasn't I'm date
like there was so much change that it
was so overwhelming but I realized that
I could can't handle it and I'm still
standing and I feel like I'm stronger
than before so I think it just taught me
that you know you might be thinking that
this is like the hardest thing and I'm
never going to come out of it but you
will and I definitely learned that
during that time I love that we're gonna
wrap up here but yeah just so many
pushes so much love coming in for you I
mean really quick marry be wants know
are you and Devan living together no we
talked about
I mean we like spend so much time
together and we live 10 minutes 10
minutes down the road but like I said
I've just been through so much change I
think that's definitely not something I
want to rush but we definitely could at
this point I think it just the timing
has to be right so you're happy but you
want to take things a little bit slower
right now yeah yes I think I think The
Bachelor taught me honestly that I'm
just I for me at least personally I want
to take things a little bit slower this
time around and and not rush anything
well so happy to see you so happy I
really cannot top this rose' enough you
guys as you know I love my rosiness and
this one is really top and it's from
Provence which is where all the good
roses my one roll everybody makes sure
of course to follow Lauren on social
media if you don't already and you also
have your clothing as well yes you did
yeah so Bellevue the label Bellevue is
actually the street I grew up on so
that's kind of where it all stems from
but yeah we did a collection of five
pieces just fun to kind of like test and
see what people liked but honestly more
so because I wanted clothes that I loved
to wear the summer so I was like oh
let's make some clothes some clothes
good great go but yeah so it's been
really fun I've been really busy but I
love clothes and I love rose a so it
kind of already accent would you ever do
reality TV again not right now no no
maybe in the future it depends on what
it would be for because I never want to
say never but for now probably not
anything you would think you'd want to
do I know if I would have the time right
yeah anything I think I would want to do
the only thing I can think of TV related
that I would ever probably do right now
at this point is like if someone were
like here go fix up this house love it
go decorate like okay you're like I know
I'm gonna decorate a house for myself so
yeah why am i close that's wonderful
okay Lauren Bushnell thank you so much
for being here guys thank you for
watching us with this crazy Bachelorette
morning of tons of Bachelorette content
that we've had here at roses and Rose
day live on ET you can of course check
out roses in Rose AR my recap is going
up on youtube today
and you know we'll just all continue to
obsess and drink our wine thank you
everybody
[Music]